[تصفيق]
صراعات خفيه وعالميه بين الحزبين الجمهوري
والديمقراطي في مجلس النواب الامريكي
معركه رفع سقف الدين العام تاخذ الطبعا
مختلفا هذا العام سياسيا واقتصاديا
حوالي 61 مره في السنوات الست الماضيه
ويدعي الديمقراطيون انها مساله روتينيه
فقط لا غير والجدل الدائر الان حول ما اذا
كان رفع سقف الدين العام ضروريا للحفاظ
على استمرار الاقتصاد ولا اعتقد ان
المساله ستطول كثيرا بين الطرفين لان
التاثيرات ستطالب كل الاسواق العالميه
وليس فقط السوق الامريكيه
الجمهوريون المحافظون يطالبون بفرض
تخفيضات في الميزانيه من اجل الموافقه على
رفع سقف الدين العام ويسرون على انهم لا
يريدون ان تتخلف الدوله عن السداد في حين
يرفض الديمقراطيون اي اجراء فيما يتعلق
بالديون خاصه في ظل الصفقه بين مكارثي
والجمهوريين المحافظين والتي افضت الى
تراسه للمجلس والتي يسرون على الكشف عن
تفاصيلها
ستصلوا الولايات المتحده الى الحد الاقصى
للديون الفيدراليه الاجماليه التي تبلغ
واحدا 31,000,000 و400 مليار دولار يوم
الخميس
وزاره الخزانه الى تدبيره خاصه يمكن في ظل
اتجاه الارادات الحالي ان تؤخر التخلف عن
السداد حتى الربيع
مماثل لما حصل عام 2001 10 من المحتمل ان
تقوم لاداره الامريكيه ببعض التحفيظات في
بعض المجلات الوا لا الامر الذي يمكن ان
يسمح للمجلس النواب ان يقول انه انتصر في
المعركه ولكن من غير المحتمل المشهد اي
اجراء كبير
وتسبب في التخلف عن السداد فان نطاق
العواقب يشمل انهيار سوق الاوراق الماليه
والركود ومعدلات فائده اعلى للمستهلكين
وضعف الضلعر وخفض التصنيف الائتمان
للولايات المتحده وحكومه غير قادره على
الوفاء بجميع التزاماتها من تمويل الجيش
لتقديم خدمات الضمان الاجتماعيه
استحقاق كبير في انتظار الكونجرس في
الساعات وحتى الايام المقبله فاما غرق
البلاد في ركودا عميق وما التحرك بسرعه
لتمرير تشريع يعالج حدود الدين حتى لا
يكون هناك فرصه المخاطره بتخلف كارثي
لسداده ديون ريتا سليمان العربيه واشنطن